it's just very difficult like I was kind
of oh my god scared the [ __ ] out of the
other goes cold some hey today with the
sadar cells we are going to go eat
Indonesian food I only got introduced to
Indonesian food recently by my friend
Yuri and if you guys don't know Peter
and Yoshi are in the median the
Indonesian Aires [ __ ] they were born
there that's why they talks so [ __ ]
fast and on top of that they actually
speak the language so why the [ __ ] not
with us up there chickens are they yeah
that about note you got got a guy on
edge one for the dog what is here just
for your guys's reference if you've
never heard the Indonesian language you
should go watch this one movie called
the raid Indonesia sounds like
Vietnamese Filipino and a pinball
machine had a baby
well I mean that's not gonna cut it in
on that is this point whatever no it's
like super fast language oh look at this
what neo-nazi tampon that means a
mixed-race yeah so I think once you pour
this thing into your plate it turns into
mixed rice [ __ ] idiot running
Indonesian is just as hard as is
pronouncing it oh I want you to try this
rujak so I'm gonna black dude
Oh chicken satay I can say that
[ __ ] oh okay you gotta meet
this hello Venus read this whole thing I
know a home girl named is nice me she
carry rende you ever like fall asleep on
the keyboard that's what it looks like
Nazi camping kalamata olives there was a
very interesting Indonesian drink that
we
I doubt it was named after a Mexican guy
named John Doe no you guys gotta try
this this is one of Asians and specialty
drinks it's still in practice you can
tell that a lot of Asian people they
don't give a [ __ ] about aesthetics kind
of the hell would you put something
green sauce on a green gram go together
yeah for Dookie judge Rick Duke oh that
is really sweet you know it tastes like
it's like liquid french toast
so what they do is they pick a french
toast squeeze it and then they put some
Indonesia in there it's pretty good if
you guys have a sweet tooth and you like
that flavor profile then you can't go
wrong with mr. Kondo Gonzalez my hands
are like always freezing yeah I know
you're like a girl all the time go ahead
those hands are always cool you're
different you're boy we're did you mean
buddy I like this it's culturally
insensitive one of the interesting
things that I observed Yoshi doing was
him eating the food with his hands which
I didn't know what the Indonesian thing
because that's an Indian thing also a
Filipino thing girl brother chopsticks
we will not be shopping we were 10 we're
weekend American magazine don't need you
people don't sharpen your answers that's
Indiana's clock dude I've never seen
that before which i think is fantastic I
used to do that
I feel punished so I don't know what the
[ __ ] that was about it it's interesting
this is like my favorite type of noodle
it's called me kata which is like
rubberband noodles it's like really
really thick noodles say a seer and a
with like coconut milk and all that's
really good it's hard to kind of like
categorize what it is reminds we have a
little bit of like Thai idiot everything
like that
that's just potatoes tofu missing yeah
cucumber hahaha ok pronounced had it in
here I don't know good all right
Oh couple things I'm good at any model
yeah everybody who works out in ten feet
like there's no be like maniacs you
think your expect out nothing job you
don't work out what do you look like
that than you [ __ ] I love that I'd say
by far the thing that I hate about Yoshi
the most is the fact that this boy got
like a six-pack he's all fit and cut he
doesn't really work out that much and he
eats twice as much as I I hate it when I
see people be worse than me their body
is perfect you should look like me dicks
like I'll eat a tic-tac and then you'll
see me gay six pounds right before you
ask you don't work out at all dude
that's [ __ ] up we found out funny
enough that Peter was a part Native
American Way
he did through this thing like I guess
is where you swab and you put it into a
tube and you send it out there's
laughing I'll find out region wise where
you're from he actually found out that
he's like half Native American dude I
work out like sometimes with a gang it
was just that Native American genus 50
it's [ __ ] you up it's your spirit
animal it's just grab there's a slot so
we ordered this rice dish you had like a
hard-boiled egg and some meat on it and
you were supposed to put what I thought
was gravy or what I thought was soup on
it but apparently it was gravy and I
drank it and it's gonna add the
consistency of cow semen not that I've
ever had that before
nothing supposed to do that I take a
code in my mouth is like so pick you
used to that kind of Stephanie mother I
know if I am a survivor had come before
I just did a the vent
I'm not going to eight come it's more
people's food a penalty so I have never
had that wise I feel I look it from your
brother's feet it's like people always
say that like the cigar so brothers are
the cutest things on earth and the only
reason why you say that is because you
don't really know them the way I do they
burp ridiculously loud
the best fruit noise coming from we used
to like go at it with burping on this
that's why both of us have really long
verses of enough but then he like got
decent or something of weird speaking
Hindi Yoshi has like this disgusting
ability to be able to push out his gut
as far as possible three months it's
nasty
I don't understand how he does it my
stomach is like that naturally I don't
even trust okay it's good first off
let's start with this [ __ ] yo she's here
you smell like a [ __ ] it just smells
like [ __ ] Ivysaur bud Davis or ball
grab like what I think was I went big it
into my face I couldn't help but hate it
but at the same time I was like you know
what it smells like an open field in
springtime yeah was like your lips as he
keeps getting me and it tastes like it
tastes like flowers hi this is smell so
fruity he just absorbed all the smell in
the bud and he just left it in there I
may use it when I'm ready are you gonna
cut it any time soon soon as somebody
pays me to do stop stroking your hair
look into my eyes it's weird it's
uncomfortable it's like I'm gonna kind
of real some you know ha ha you [ __ ]
look like Prince